[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il paraît que les familles heureuses non
pas l'histoire
alors heureuse la mienne le fut mais
avec ces épreuves de la vie de toute
famille doit surmonter elle a aussi reçu
des coups d'une rare violence
et qui en réalité étaient destinées
alors ces cicatrices je vous en parlerai
pas parce qu'elles n'appartiennent qu'à
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec cette pudeur je ne transigerai pas
car c'est ma façon de protéger
c'est auquel je tiens le plus
et je sais que vous me comprendrez
[Musique]
27 ans demeure comme dirait bref c'est
la baule
merci
et merci à vous les enfants je suis si
fier
je sors par là c'est par là c'est par
exemple ce n'est pas la droite dimanche
et dessine faudrait savoir et dessine là
ils font dessinent la non je vous ai
quand même par la chjama cieux zemmouri
va me mordre voilà